どうなんかツイッターでよくシャッチョサンサットサンと言われるんですよ
シャットさんって何か
嬉しいですね可愛いらしい
シャット参加する
おっ
エプ気取って処刑って言うんでしょ始めそけ
me
2今日は一番端この連
投げにくそうです
おかしいでしょああっ
あーもーなんかあれですかご当地ご当地キャラみたいな感じでいけとおかしいでしょ
えっ
もうこれも他の人ですからでもめぐー員さんじゃないですか
まずはオレがオレにオンデマンド web みんなふっ
をへ
ためのパンツ被ってもどんなんですけどもねーみたいな感じですか
おかしいでしょオンラインマンってもすごいと同出たらオンライン万人
ぷっ
できないなぁいい2浪
なんかすごいよくそんなの思いつきますねぼく逃げてく下げないですよ
プーラー
うーん2こんにちはてなお慣れて欲しいでしょ
雲よ入ってゆけだよ
まあいろんなコメントがあったんですけどなんかホが今のへっこんでたくさんあったん
ですよ恥ほいっていうのは多かったし
まぁきっと僕は真の方にしたかったんですよね端ぽいとか
あと中一平社員とか社員とかそういう感じが多かったんですけど僕の新しい名前はです
ね
肇社長です
バッハ
いやーけど聞いてください今までとは違いますからね
やっぱりこう会社の多さって書いたらもう会社の多さじゃないですかけど僕会社の誤差
じゃないんで
やっぱり会社のおっしゃっぽさって友情使っちゃダメなんですよ
なんで
表記の仕方をですねー
普通にはずねぇ
でこっちを
あれです
ひらがなにします
2つを
殺王
まぁこはすることによってねもうさ鳥っていう言葉に会社 no さっていう面は元
なくなってもう
なんていうんだろうまあいたがわかるでしょ会社の多さじゃないんですけど社長って
いう名前なんです
なんで
僕のことを
あの感じで言わないでください大事なことですこれは
感じで読んだら会社でいじめられるんでダメですよ平原で読んでいただきたいです皆外
にコメントありがとうございました
まあ基本的にも始めさんって反映さんってよや
始めたんだよ仕方ないときだけ
社長ってつけるみたいな感じねぇ
おいきたいと思うんで雛形の外れ冊をですまあ海外に行くことがあったらねローマ字に
なると思う
またその時わー
宜しくお願いします
じゃん
あそたまにれなんかこうやって
何と言うだろう
コメントを読むことがあるんで皆さんよかったらねまた
コメントとか
高評価とか
一羽目にしてデータ高くのターンがありがたいです
the